Tim would have never spilled water can
you believe live on the show he actually
hasn't he actually
I think
it's a big ego and he thinks I can do
this show Tim you don't see them he's
like you should have done this you
should oh not only that I saw Jack
lastly it's worse than that I got him
sick actually I coughed in his dream
house I said I said I'm gonna be the
host the next time
you know he he's he's a king he comes in
he owns he absolutely has the moves
Sheamus was thinking obviously anyone
could do this I said I said it's Child's
Play turns out it's harder than he
thinks no I didn't I mean I think we are
there we're I'm gonna return to the
point here because we can talk about
endless number of Joe Biden gas my
personal favorite was when he was in
Ireland and said I don't want to go home
that's one statement did he say I don't
want to go home when he was in Ireland
he also said he's not Irish because none
of his relatives are drunk or in jail
well